THESE ARE REAL QUESTIONS.
>> AGREED.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU, MARK,
I APPRECIATE IT?
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE THE ONLY
ONE WHO COMES ON.
THE MEDIA HAVE HAD A LOT OF
FUN PUSHING UNPROVED CLAIMS
BETWEEN TRUMP AND RUSSIA,
OKAY.
NOW, HERE IS ANOTHER ANGLE
YOU MAY NOT HAVE SEEN,
CLAIMS THE NRA HAS BEEN
PENETRATED BY THE RUSSIANS
SOMEHOW AS WELL.
KIM STRASSEL IS ON THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" EDITORIAL
BOARD AND SHE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
I ALMOST CAN'T KEEP UP WITH
THE VARIOUS THINGS THE LEFT
DOESN'T LIKE CLAIM
PENETRATED BY RUSSIA.
UNPACK THIS GLUT CONSPIRACY
THEORY FOR US IF YOU WOULD.
>> WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR THIS
ONE, TUCKER, IT'S BY THE
VERY SAME PEOPLE THAT
BROUGHT US THE DOSSIER
CLAIMS AS WELL.
YOU REMEMBER THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN HIRES THIS FUSION
GPS TO COMMISSION THE
DOSSIER.
IT COMES UP WITH THESE
FANTASTICAL DOSSIER CLAIMS.
AND WHAT'S IT DO?
IT GOES TO THE FBI IN ORDER
TO GIVE THEM SOME
LEGITIMACY.
EVEN THOUGH NOTHING IN IT
HAS BEEN CORROBORATED.
NOTHING HAS BEEN PROVED.
ONCE THE FBI SAID IT WAS
DOING AN INVESTIGATION, THEN
EVERYONE TOOK IT SERIOUSLY.
SO NOW WHAT WE HAVE IS SAME
PEOPLE, FUSION GPS THAT HAVE
BEEN PEDDLING TO THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AND
OTHERS THEIR ARGUMENT GLENN
SIMPSON THE HEAD OF FUSION
GPS.
THAT THE NRA HAS QUOTE BEEN
INFILTRATED BY THE RUSSIANS.
THEIR TOP LEADERSHIP AND
RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN FILTERING
MONEY THROUGH THE NRA AND
DID DURING 2016 TO HELP
TRUMP HE HAS NO EVIDENCE FOR
THIS.
WE SEE THE MEDIA RUNNING
AFTER IT AND SUDDENLY LOTS
OF STORIES OF HIS CLAIM
WITHOUT A SHRED OF EVIDENCE.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE VERY
SMART PEOPLE ON THE LEFT AND
SOME OF THEM WHO ARE
SELF-AWARE.
HAS ANYONE SAID MAYBE THIS
IS MASS HYSTERIA.
IF EVERYTHING WE DON'T LIKE,
EVERY POPULAR MOVEMENT WE
DISAGREE WITH IF OUR
INSTINCT IS TO BLAME UNSEEN
SABOTEURS FROM RUSSIA, MAYBE
WE ARE CRAZY.
HAS ANYBODY SAID THAT?
>> NOPE, NOT THAT I HAVE
HEARD OF.
AS YOU KNOW AND I KNOW THERE
IS SUCH AN INTEREST ON
RUSSIA SOMEHOW CONNECTING IT
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
SUGGESTING THERE ARE
NEFARIOUS THINGS HAPPENING
AROUND EVERY CORNER IN IS
VERY CONCERNING.
THERE IS NOT ONE JOT OF
EVIDENCE TO THIS, ALL RIGHT?
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> GLENN SIMPSON SAID THIS
IN TESTIMONY.
HE MENTIONED SOME RANDOM
RUSSIAN NAMES.
HE COULD PROVIDE NO EVIDENCE
OF MONEY TRANSFERS, ANY
PERSONS NAMED IN THE NRA WHO
SUPPOSEDLY TOOK IT YET, YOU
HAVE NEWSPAPER OUTLETS LIKE
MCCLATCHEY WHO CONTINUED TO
RUN NEWSPAPER ARTICLES
GIVING TREATED DENSE TO
THIS.
IT HAS PLATLY DENIED IT.
ANYONE INVOLVED WITH THIS
HAS FLATLY DENIED IT
APPARENTLY ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO THESE DAYS IS COME UP
WITH A CONSPIRACY, HAVE
HOUSE DEMOCRATS GIVE IT
CREDENCE AND THEN SUDDENLY
IT'S LEGITIMATE.
>> Tucker: OUR LEADERS ARE
OUT OF CONTROL.
EMOTIONALLY THEY ARE OUT OF
CONTROL.
THEY ARE CHILDREN.
IT'S SCARY, ACTUALLY.
IT'S HAVING A BIG EFFECT.